It’s hard to find a modern movie that doesn’t
flaunt it’s CGI in your face.
And while that’s not necessarily a bad thing,
audiences come to assume that the medium is
used strictly for monsters, explosions, and
superpowers.
And while that might be true to an extent,
there are a lot more instances of subtle manipulation
than you might realize.
A little softening here, a little lens flare
there, and suddenly the whole movie is completely
different.
Before we jump in to the entries, we wanted
to say thanks for watching.
And invite you to subscribe to our channel
to see more of our stuff.
You can even join the notification squad for
updates on when we release new stuff, just
for you.
And hey, can you guess the movie based on
these emojis?
Stay tuned for the answer, and play along
with our trivia questions as we go through
the entries.
Here are 10 CGI Movie Moments That Completely
Fooled You!
John Wick
If you’ve seen John Wick, you know that
there’s almost nothing funny about it.
In fact, it’s probably one of the most violent
movies in recent memory.
And for good reason.
So while a lot of the rage on screen is very
real, a smaller, stinkier element was added
in post.
The audience doesn’t get a lot of time to
bond with Wick’s adorable puppy friend,
but Daisy makes an impression regardless.
And even got her own CGI specialist.
The her charming little turds are 100% fake.
A classic case of Hollywood tampering— even
the poop is perfect.
Gladiator
Sadly, Hollywood has lost many great performers
over the last twenty years.
And when an actor passes away during filming,
not only does it take an emotional toll on
the cast, crew, and loved ones, but it also
poses a tricky logistical hurdle.
Especially if they hadn’t finished filming
their scenes.
When Oliver Reed passed in 1999, Gladiator
hadn’t wrapped shooting and the crew scrambled
to find a solution for the rest of his scenes.
Using earlier footage, they were able to map
Reed’s face from earlier scenes onto another
body, and brilliantly synthesize the rest
of his performance.
The Social Network
Before The Social Network, nobody had heard
the name Armie Hammer.
So when he showed up in duplicate, everyone
just assumed the casting director came across
some super hot twins.
And considering how clean the CGI is, we can’t
blame you for that.
But it turns out Earth is not that lucky,
and there’s only one Armie Hammer playing
two characters.
Depending on who you are, the Winklevoss twins
are either the inventors of Facebook or butt-hurt
frat bros.
But we can all agree on one thing: they’re
dang handsome.
Furious 7
After Paul Walker’s untimely death in November
2013, the Furious 7 crew found themselves
in a similar predicament as the team from
Gladiator.
A half finished performance, devastated community,
and unforgivable Hollywood deadlines all put
pressure on the team behind the scenes.
And it was the actor’s brothers who came
to the rescue.
Production used them as stand-ins for their
late sibling, and the computer wizards on
staff mapped Paul’s face on to them, completing
the performance.
With all the chases, explosions, and general
eye-candy contained in the Fast and Furious
franchise, there’s a lot to distract audiences.
So if you fell for it, you’re not alone.
Theory of Everything
Stephen Hawking is one of the most brilliant
minds to ever grace this planet.
And its about time the man got his own dang
movie.
Eddie Redmayne bravely signed on to portray
the genius in 2014’s The Theory of Everything.
Chronicling his life, the film inevitably
shows the intense impact ALS has on Hawking’s
body.
And while Remayne’s performance is detail-oriented
and accurate, there are some symptoms that
can’t be faked without a little help.
In one shot focusing on his twitching muscles,
the filmmakers layered two different takes
on top of each other to get the effect.
The first was a still closeup, and in the
next the actor flexed and wiggled his fingers
to mimic the erratic twitches.
Ant Man
If you saw Ant Man and found yourself thinking
about how great Michael Douglas is looking
these days, congratulations: you’re a sucker.
It’s not a raw food diet, botox, or anything
else Gwyneth Paltrow might be shilling on
Instagram.
It’s good old-fashioned post-production
manipulation.
CGI softening and blurring were used to get
that big screen babyface glow.
People in the ‘biz call it “beauty work”.
Obviously the filmmakers got into a whole
lot of computer-generated shenanigans to bring
the story of Ant Man to life, but we thought
they might have just used some trick-lighting
and makeup to bring the actor back thirty
years.
Forrest Gump
He may be in a wheelchair, but we know Lieutenant
Dan could kick our sorry asses in a fight.
The Vietnam vet and commanding officer has
seen carnage we can’t even fathom.
And even though he’s a hard-drinking, chain-smoking
son of a gun, deep down we know he’s a good
guy.
One of Forrest Gump’s BFF’s, Dan is a
double amputee.
Considering the film was released in 1994,
and before the CGI boom, you might assume
Gary Sinise is in a clever costume.
Or maybe even sitting atop an optical illusion.
But you’d be wrong.
CGI strikes again!
Nightcrawler link
The man bun: not since the mullet has there
been a hairstyle so controversial.
But usually all it takes is one brave celeb
to bring a questionable style into the mainstream.
So when Jake Gyllenhaal rocked a little pony
atop his noggin in 2014’s Nightcrawler,
people lost their minds.
Advocates were stoked about having a celebrity
endorser, and dissenters had to pretend that
they didn’t like the actor anymore.
But deep down, no-one can deny their love
for the Gyllenhaals.
And when we found out that the hair-don’t
was occasionally CGI’d onto his head, we
realized that he was the victim in this scenario.
The Wolf of Wall Street
To be fair, there is a lot going on in The
Wolf of Wall Street.
Sex, drugs, money, and all around debauchery
fill its entire one hundred and eighty minutes.
And in true Scorsese fashion, it’s chockfull
of Hollywood’s biggest and brightest stars.
So if you missed a few things here and there,
we really can’t blame you.
Obviously a lot of movies are shot on sound
stages and cleaned up in post.
But when we learned that almost every single
backdrop in Wolf of Wall Street is computer-generated,
we were blown away.
It’s so expertly blended that, even if you
pulled your eyes off of Margot Robbie, you
still wouldn’t notice.
If I Stay
Actors go through all sorts of training in
preparation for whatever upcoming role they’ve
signed on to do.
And when it came to learning cello for her
role in If I Stay, Chloe Grace Moretz gave
it the old college try.
The actress spent countless hours working
on her musical skills but she never got good
enough to convincingly fake it for the camera.
Luckily for her, there was a CGI wizard ready
to step in and fix things.
Production used a body double for the cello
scenes and digitally laid the actress’ face
over top.
So instead of complimenting her musical ability,
give a high five to the FX guy instead.
And the answer to the movie emoji is: ______________.
What do you think?
Were you fooled by any of the moments on our
list?
Tell us in the comments, and subscribe our
YouTube channel for more of cool stuff.
Join the notification squad and get alerts
when we post new content!
You definitely won’t regret it.
Thanks for watching.